hi but he can't get off the ground he
could definitely apply swings are back
against the man I think that's what
shocked everybody is that he just
doesn't play like a rookie plays like
the seasoned vet side of the glass again
that's just a bet move right there
that's not a boob area see a rookie
pulling on a consistent basis guys
record 183 guys clever player obviously
big big man seven feet one's got a lot
of bling all rich partridge
back to LA cleans up off the bounce to
11 years for a lot of Washington's we've
done you at a husband
behind-the-back pass over there
that's what maybes 311 heads AG goes
overage and rules in losing an Indiana
tonight by five
Aldridge goes down on his feet forces to
fall back out to Mills for to shoot down
to three marches for three he can hit
he's got down of the Mitchell
inside twisted turn it goes on got to go
down from start offensively la is will
those games is coming along on a
conveyor belt Aldridge with a turnaround
jumper this is gone for a pretty much
any team in my opinion no guys gonna
defend shoot some footballs poor he's
got a big body's beat you up in LA Rubio
got a stamp on it
Aldridge tough shot 104 10 on the shot
clock
gay double-team LA back to Marcus 9 on
the shot clock
Rubio show the hand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]